[Music]
is going to be a special one because I'm
joined by five Super inspiring people
from the cloud Community we have Prasad
Ashish Julie Neil and Sammy We're going
to hear about this career experiences
the challenges they faced as well as any
strategies and tips that have helped
them along their Cloud Journey so before
we get started please let us know in the
chat where you're tuning in from so I'm
Bas Sydney and our panelists are joining
from all around the world also comment
below where you are on your Cloud
Learning Journey are you a beginner or
are you someone who's been in Cloud for
a few years now I wanted to mention as
well that we have some exciting
giveaways for all of you who are
cheating in live in the chat you should
to see a signup form to enter a draw for
some Cloud Le for some Cloud Learning
Resources from whizlabs and digital
cloud training so 10 lucky winners will
get 6 months of free access to whizlabs
AWS sandbox and another 10 will get 12
months of access to the AWS Cloud
practitioner automate training package
from digital cloud training so 20 prizes
up for grabs and winners will be
randomly selected and contacted after
the live
stream okay with all that being said
let's get started so to kick things off
I'd like each of our panelists to
introduce themselves maybe we can start
from uh the top and then we can go down
to the bottom row as well just from left
to right so starting off with the Shish
could you tell us a bit about yourself
your role in cloud and how you got to
where you are
now thanks Lucy for having me and
obviously this is a good privilege to
have name starting with a so that you
get first and it's good and bad in some
cases
uh so I would start my name is asish and
I'm a technical trainer in AWS been
working in Cloud Technologies from
around eight years now previously in
private Cloud VMware and now in awsn I
do deliver Technical Training on a
day-to-day basis that is my day job
thanks for having
me awesome thanks for joining today uh
next we have
Julie hi everyone my name is Julie
alkins um I started out
uh my cloud Journey back in
2018 um I got a job at Linux Academy in
2019 and just have continued to kind of
roll since then I am now a senior exam
prep curriculum developer at AWS so I
create all of the exam prep content for
the AWS
certifications um on the AWS exam prep
team excited to be here nice to meet you
well virtually
Lucy cool thanks joining today uh Neil
thanks lisy yeah hi everyone so I'm Neil
Davis uh I'm the founder of digital
cloud training um I started my it career
back in the late 90s so roughly sort of
25 years ago now um so on some very
early technology I used certifications
to get into the industry uh and then
ended up as a Solutions architect
working Consulting roles uh about five
years ago I then sort of Switched gears
a little bit and decided to take up uh
training so now I I run the training
company digital cloud training and we
teach people all over the
world nice okay uh Sammy hi my name is
Samy CH I am a cloud evangelist right
now I work as a principal solution
architect have been in it about 30 years
and have been uh actively doing my cloud
journey in the last five years so I
basically using Cloud to S people
solution and also enjoy encourage people
to use the this amazing technology to
help you advance your
career
thanks Amy and last but not least we
have
Prasad hello everyone I'm Prasad ra I
started my career as a net developer
back in
2007 and I've been mainly invol net
development architecting till 2019
that's when my cloud Journey started
when I joined AWS and now I work as a
principal Solutions architect at AWS
helping customers migrate and modernize
Don applications
onws
awesome okay I'm just having a look at
the comments now and we have people who
have um commented where they're tuning
in from so really just people tuning in
from everywhere we have people from
India the US uh Canada
Europe uh Kenya South Africa so yeah
from all corners of the world so welcome
to the live stream everyone uh so next
question I'd like to ask the panelists
is around what you like doing the most
um in your your day-to-day job so what
excites you the most um this time let's
start off with
prad sure yeah as I said in my current
role I help the customers and partners
uh migrate and modernize their net
applications on us so it's not just net
applications but it's doet applications
and Microsoft workloads so I come from a
Microsoft workload uh background so when
there was an opening at AWS uh they
needed someone who has experience with
net applications uh and I was very CED
in the interview saying that no I do not
have any AWS or Cloud experience but
they were fine with that so when I came
into AWS uh I rammed up on AWS within
the first three months and I started uh
shadowing a lot uh with the customers
and the partners uh to see how you know
they do along with my other Solutions
Architects and as of now the best thing
that I like about uh the my job is the
autonomy that we get in the role as a
Solutions architect uh we get a lot of
autonomy in terms of understanding what
the customer requirements are and then
accordingly working backward from there
to design a solution for
them just as a followup on what you said
about autonomy uh since I worked as a
Solutions Artic before I know that the
role is also quite diverse as in you get
to work on a lot of different tasks uh
not just technical uh side of helping
customers but also running your own side
projects and things internally within
the company and I know you Pride you've
launched the uh essay like be become an
essay program and also you've recently
uh launched the book along with asish so
would you like to share a bit about the
book launch and the process with coming
up with that
idea yeah sure so like I said when I
started with AWS I had zero Cloud
experience and when I was able to come
into AWS lot of my previous colleagues
started reaching out to me that how can
they transition their career to cloud
and that's where my mentoring Journey
starts so I started helping few of of my
previous colleagues and started sharing
my journey on LinkedIn that's when a lot
of people started reaching out and I
started mentoring them over the weekend
but I was doing it alone so it was not
scalable but then there were other folks
in AWS who are doing it in their own
capacity like Ashish was doing similar
thing Jamila she was doing similar
things so few of us amazonians in UK we
came together to start a free mentoring
initiative called Bessa become a
Solutions
architect and uh we have been doing like
we have done four batches around each
batch is of 12 weeks 8 weeks we focus on
Technical and four weeks we focus on
behavioral Solutions architect is not
just technical but a lot of Behavioral
is involved in it like how do you manage
customer expectations how do you do
whiteboarding and others things in that
mentoring experience the one common
feedback that we have heard is there is
lot of technical material available uh
to get into Cloud but people are still
confused about the path that they should
be taking to navigate the cloud career
and that's where the idea came about if
we are able to showcase the paths of
other people who have been able to
transition their career into cloud or
who have been excelling in their Cloud
career that might be helpful to others
like what decisions they have made what
learnings they have had what resources
they have used to transition their
career and that the book is all about
compiling the stories of people at
different career stages different
backgrounds that they are coming from
and different career aspirations and
putting them in a structure and showc
faing their Journey for everyone others
to get inspired and while writing this
leag me and Ashish we have been so
inspired by the journeys of everyone
like you Lucy uh Julie Sammy Neil each
of you have such a unique Journey right
so it's very
inspiring thanks for sharing yeah I
think uh I think it'll be super valuable
for people who are listening to read the
book uh it's not live yet I think it's
going to be available for uh orders in a
couple of hours um I think about 6 hours
so for those who are watching later on
um I'll leave a link below where you can
uh check out the book and uh maybe get a
copy for yourself so yeah the book is
called Cloud career Journeys okay so
moving on to you Sammy um what would you
say is the most uh most enjoyable part
of your job I think is um you got new
difficulty or challenge every single day
and no two customer the same there are
some similarity but they are different
so problem solving is like what I like
to do the most so that's what I like so
like for example today I may talk about
health and healthcare industry tomorrow
maybe Aerospace and I say I don't know
Aerospace then I say well you don't know
anything when you born just learn it and
how you learn start learning that's why
I I really enjoy the book uh and also
this Jour is I I can see the challenge
I'm facing other people are facing
similar but you have to start your day
one y uh following up from that do you
think think there's been any interesting
uh challenges recently that you'd like
to share more about I think is um not
reason I would say the challenge is
every day you have to have the mindset
to change the change mindset I usually
fix because being an engineer I like to
fix problem but now it's like you have
to change and break so what I find the
biggest challenge is like once we get
used to do a good job at what you are
doing you do not want to change but that
prevent you to go to the next level and
and that is actually stop us from doing
great you see I have this jacket I want
to do this because I want to show before
I get this jacket I don't think about
this before that I'm running marathon
before I run marathon five years before
that I make the decision I going to
train for Marathon so same thing for the
cloud Journey or anyone's career you
have to think go back uh you have to
find backward what have you done make
you here today then think forward what
should you do today to go to tomorrow
and once you have the mindset to
overcome that challenge you will be the
another story that everyone want to
learn from
you yeah I agree I think that sounds
super inspiring and uh for those who are
not too sure what the golden jacket is
it's pretty much uh when you get all of
your certifications um AWS gives you
that golden jacket that you can wear um
and a lot of people would wear that to
events like AWS re event or maybe AWS
Summit to then show people you know um
they have like all the certifications
and people might ask them questions and
advice and tips around that uh so moving
on to Neil I know we're kind of in a
similar space with helping people uh get
into the cloud and get hired what would
you say is the most uh enjoyable part to
your job well I think I'm I'm sure you'd
agree that it's a bit of a privilege to
be a full-time educator it's it's
fantastic I I love teaching I love I
love passing on what I've learned to
other people and so for me um over the
last several years mostly that's been
around video training so and I love the
creative aspects of that where you know
trying to work out how can I articulate
this knowledge how can I make sure that
people who come from a background where
they may not understand any of what I'm
talking about and then slowly over time
bring them up to speed so that they can
earn their own certifications and get
into the industry so that's that's been
something I've been really enjoying and
then over the last couple of years we've
been doing live training as well and for
me that's been a huge change something I
really enjoy doing because now you're
not just pre-recording it and sending it
out to the world you're actually in
front of people you can actually have a
conversation you can actually see them
progress and get to know them so yeah I
love that aspect of the training
there as a as a next question to that um
do you have any uh kind of success
stories that you'd like to share about
any of your students um maybe people who
have gone through the program or maybe
um brought a course and ended up
learning a cloud job wow I mean we we
have so many I mean through obviously we
have a large very large number of people
who bought our online training so in
that regard it's usually just messages
that we receive you know in our LinkedIn
or in our slack or something like that
saying thanks so much we see those every
single day that they've got their you
know past certifications or they've got
the you know got through into a job as
well um in our boot camp program we we
get to know people a bit better so then
we actually see the journeys so um you
know without mentioning any specific
names we've seen some people for example
go from uh literally no background in it
whatsoever and literally in about three
months go into a position um that's
that's a really fast turnaround that's
not necessarily what everyone can do um
but if you put in the work you know this
is someone who's really highly motivated
uh they turn out to class they do all
the project work we assigned them have a
great attitude and it's amazing what you
can do in a few months if you if you
really sort of put yourself into that
into that position and take advantage of
those
opportunities yeah I think it's so cool
how these days there's so many free
resources and just the extensive amount
of options available uh for learning
cloud I remember back then um I'm sure
all of you as well when we first started
there wasn't as many and the community
wasn't you know as big so really good to
see how far it's come and I agree with
you I think it is really a privilege to
be able to contribute to this um
full-time and be able to kind of work
with um work alongside everyone and see
everyone's uh Journeys whether that's
kind of like getting a comment or maybe
um seeing them progress through more
personal mentoring so moving on to you
Julie uh what do you say is a part of
your job that you really
enjoy probably the learning because I'm
still I still feel like a newbie um
because you most people have a lot more
years of experience than I do um but to
create the exam prep courses and the
content you have to have that knowledge
and so as a newbie I'm every day dealing
with that impostor syndrome so you know
by um like Neil said and you said
helping other people learn um it helps
me as well helps me with the Imposter
syndrome it helps me with my depth and
my technical accuracy on the course
contents um so that's probably my
favorite part and then um being involved
in the community uh you know because I
always say that training is personal you
know I learn differently than most
people and so it's one of the things
with my training that I really try to
focus on is hitting that train training
you know for like a newbie or a mid or
senior engineer level um so it's it's
it's just it's a lot of fun and daily
learning I really enjoy
it I think I feel the same uh there's
always so much to learn especially last
year with all of the generative AI
announcements and seeing generative AI
being integrated across all these uh
cloud services so um I'm sure there's
also people who are in the chat who are
already working in cloud and maybe also
facing that uh similar dilemma of having
to constantly keep up to date with
things to learn uh do you have any tips
Julie on um how people can upskill and
just stay uh up to date with the latest
trends I for me personally it's being
involved in the community so there's all
these different programs like the AWS
Community Builders is a fantastic one um
but or different slack channels but a
lot of times in these communities when
you join and you participate you'll see
people ask questions that you wanted to
ask or you maybe didn't know you needed
to ask and so that takes your depth of
learning a little bit deeper um and then
you also build networking you know and
so you get new friends um and it's it's
it's just a really great community and
um it helps with
um if you are looking for a job you can
get referrals and it just kind of
escalates from there
so cool yeah yep uh I think it's good
how you mentioned the AWS Community
Builders program because applications
are still open for this year's intake so
uh in the next few moments I'll put a
link in the chat uh for those of you who
are maybe interested in applying uh so
Ashish what would you say uh is the most
enjoyable part of being a Solutions
architect for
you yeah for me U I've been into
training a lot and for me it's like a
dream come true kind of because I'm a
full-time trainer and I I've been into
both side of the delivery of the
training when it was purely a classroom
training so we would travel to different
places go to customer environment train
them learn from them understand what
challenges they are facing and when you
explain something to a learner and when
they they understand it then you could
see the light bulb moment at their face
right okay I understood it now I was
struggling and you were able to help me
out so that satisfaction when you see
somebody saying hey I understood it
thank you so much and probably I will go
ahead further and I will do something
and people again as Neil said that
people reach out to you that I passed
certification I was able to land a job I
was able to crack an interview so that
is what makes me feel that okay I'm
doing something which is at least
helping at least one single person and I
want to keep on doing that thing so that
is one aspect of my actual job which I
do on eight hour basis every day the
second aspect is being in AWS like I get
lot of flexibility so I'm able to use
similar type of resources and create it
for Community also so like I hosted
resources about analogies on my website
I authored few books and the one book we
are authoring right we authored with
Prasad which is also in the similar line
like how can we make people's learning
Learning Journey better it could be
through resources it could be through
motivation it could be through sharing
the journeys of other people like we
have all here so that that's the
interesting part about my
job awesome thanks for sharing I think I
said Solutions architect for your job
but uh yeah she is a technical trainer a
technical instructor so let's move on to
the next question uh which is around
what you said asish around like the
challenges that you know uh people
usually face so I'd like to start off by
asking what are some of the challenges
that all of you have encountered in your
Cloud career and as a follow up from
that how did you overcome them uh Ashish
maybe we can start from you this time so
what would you say as some of the
challenges um challenges is that in
Cloud the things are moving very fast
space right so if you we talking and
somebody some developer is developing a
code and it is being pushed and there is
a new feature popping up tomorrow
morning so that is one challenge to keep
up with whatever is there and you have
to accept somewhere that you can't learn
everything
like when I joined AWS I started
maintaining a list that hey this XYZ
technology I do not know this feature I
do not know this I do not know over a
period of time I was not able to
checkbox everything that I am learned
that I have learned that I have learned
that I realized that it is not humanly
possible to learn everything so let me
focus on my core areas let me work on my
fundamentals first and once I have my
fundamentals right it would be much
easier for me to ramp up of anything so
that's what I started with so challenges
people face that there are so many
things within Cloud where I should go if
I have to give somebody advice I would
say focus on basic fundamentals of cloud
and once you know that ramping up
anything would be much much easier in
longer
run yep I agree I think that's also uh
focusing on learning the fundamentals
and just starting somewhere helps avoid
that analysis paralysis of like what
cloud should I learn what certification
should I do kind of just starting off
with the basics and building up from
that uh what about you Julie what would
you say are some of the challenges that
you faced in your Cloud career and also
how did you manage to overcome them for
me being a newbie uh fundamentals
because I came in as an administrative
assistant and so I was lacking basically
all all
fundamentals um
so the way I did it um and then not
having an actual job in Cloud um I have
different projects that I work on as I'm
studying for different certifications so
I sort of use
certifications to go deeper deeper
deeper um and then I had a project for
every Circ that I worked on um to help
me get that hands-on experience because
I don't have a lot of hands-on
experience so I use certification and
training and my projects to kind of get
that hands-on experience and get a
little bit more depth in there
yeah I think having oh that's okay uh I
think having that balance of like
certifications of projects is quite
important because sometimes it's like if
people heavily rely on that
certification side then forget to build
projects then you know like that uh I
guess the Practical side is kind of
missing so it's good how you're able to
kind of balance both and do both and
certifications I think it really does
map out this really good you know
Learning Journey and learning road map
what about oh sorry go ahead oh no you
you go ahead I was just going to say
when I passed the AWS certified
Solutions architect associate exam you
know like I thought that's it like I
knew it all I could do anything and then
when I started studying for the
developers you know I quickly realized
how much you know I still don't know how
much I need to learn and that's just
kind of been a momentum every new
certification every new different domain
is a whole another world of depth that
you know I don't have and I need to
learn
yeah I agree and uh I think it's cool
how there's some of these
specializations as well uh with the
certifications so you could either just
go broad or sometimes even go deeper
into like a certain subject area um so
for you Neil what would be some
challenges that you faced in your Cloud
career I guess even um now or maybe uh
when you were working as an architect
before yeah in fact I might even go back
further than that along a very similar
line because I know it's irrelevant to
so many people um you know back at the
very very beginning of my career now I
didn't have a it degree or anything like
that so um I was basically just decided
right I'm I'm interested in the world of
tech I want to get into a job and so
certifications are going to be the way
for me um and I've known other people
who went along that sort of same road so
um you know the challenge then is okay
well you you don't have any experience
I'm sure everyone's everyone's had to
solve this problem in their career you
don't have any experience you're super
Keen you start learning you get earn
some certifications how do you get that
first job and so that was a challenge
and a bit like what Julie was talking
about there projects are something
really important so you got to get the
certifications you got to get the
projects so you've got to you got to
find a way to to demonstrate what skills
you have um and what challenges and that
you've solved along the way I think
that's really important with Project
work if you can share it online along
with a story that says I'm on this
Learning Journey I've I've I've built
this projects and along the way I had
all these problems and I had to solve
this problem this is how I did it um I
came up with this solution and this is
why I came up with this solution uh and
then employers will look at that and
they'll it demonstrates a lot of things
it demonstrates that you have a good
attitude that you're Keen to learn um
and it starts mattering a lot less that
you don't have the experience and so I
think yeah finding ways to to document
that online that's a little bit
different I had to do some more creative
things at the beginning of my career we
didn't necessarily have those online
tools back in the late 90s um but we do
today so um I think yeah just finding
ways to get you know work out what you
want to do what's the job role focus on
the certifications and that you need and
that's probably going to be a broad
range of certifications not just AWS
typically need some other skills as well
uh and then find ways to sort of build
projects document them share them in a
way that you can then demonstrate them
to employers and that's that's kind of
what I did a little bit different back
in the day but that's how I got into my
my first job
awesome Yep uh I think documenting your
journey is quite important so whether
that be like a personal website a GitHub
or just posting like articles on
LinkedIn or medium so uh really good
advice there and I'm glad there's those
platforms now that are more tailored
towards providing uh job Seekers with
the ability to to be able to do that uh
so Sammy uh what would you say are some
challenges that you either face uh on a
day-to-day now or some challenges you
face in your Cloud career okay so start
with this is like one of the challenges
I doubt myself can I do this because I
don't know and I I like I say I'm a
marathon runner and when I start a
marathon I just want to test myself how
how far can I go and then learn during
the process like Julie mentioned about
earlier when I start my cloud Journey
five years ago that's not much good
material at least I can find for a cost
that I can pay then I find out that I
have that challenge so I want to pass
the how I look how I fa what uh what can
help you to speed up your journey to
make your career successful and that
also translate to business success
because people don't hire you or you
don't win a contract because you how
many search the way how fast can you
learn how can you apply those transfer
transferable skills knowledge to the
next project because something will be
new tomorrow if it's not new AI replace
you but on the other hand like know that
is another thing I also want to share
with other people do expect like
Marathon you get injury you will have
some technology you don't understand
instead say I don't understand you say
what can I learn or if I don't
understand I share other people I don't
understand do you understand suddenly
you find out that the whole community
help you to become better like you can
join a community and for me one of the
thing is I I want to tell and help
others to know that start your journey
today even you don't know do not be
afraid the whole Community going to help
you and you can go to Lucy you can go to
pass PS you can run with me cloud or on
Earth or go to Neil so many things but
no one can let you start your first step
on Marathon if you don't move your first
step so that's basically I think biggest
challenge I have and also probably
someone else
challenge yeah I like how you described
it as a marathon uh just because you
know it's going to be a long journey of
continuous learning and also there's
going to be Milestones you can celebrate
on the way uh
and yeah I agree with the community side
as well don't be afraid to just reach
out to people you know ask um questions
during live streams or just have a look
at all the videos and learning resources
out there um so for prad for you what
would you say are some of the challenges
that you faced so far in your Cloud
career and how did you overcome
them sure so like my biggest challenge
before I started Cloud career my cloud
career was procrastination and impost
syndrome I kept on you know pushing okay
you know I'm kind of comfortable in the
current job I don't need to learn new
technology you know I was that mindset
till the time you know I got a call from
AWS and I'm like sh man this is a real
good opportunity I should have learned
something but uh thankfully you know
like AWS was not looking for someone who
was expert in cloud while they were
getting in they were wanted to uh have
someone who has good technical knowledge
so I was able to get in but once I got
in that's where the Imposter syndrome
you know like hit me that everyone
around me so smart how would I ever
survive here and the only way to
overcome that was you know like
Relentless learning in the first three
months uh I I you know it's not only
just the certifications but lot of
Hands-On lab yeah once you're inside AWS
you get you know free uh adbs account to
do as many as much experiment as you
want like it was I was not just limited
to free tier ad account so I the first
three to six months I used to do a lot
of handson for anything and everything
and uh networking internally I did a lot
of internal Network working um reached
out to multiple Solutions architect and
then I was trying to see if anyone is
going into a customer meeting uh can I
Shadow them just to learn just to see
how they work and that helped me like
overcome my impos syndrome and even now
like imposter syndrome stays with you
because everyone around you is smarter
than you only way you can overcome is
you know uh keep speaking with other
people because other people also have a
similar you know like kind of imposter
syndrome then you feel that okay you're
not alone in this journey and second
learning uh keep on
learning yeah thanks for sharing the
challenges and also some really good
advice there um I think it's important
to recognize that uh everyone around you
is also learning at the same time and
everyone has like their own pace of
learning as well but yeah I think it's
back to just the idea of community and
trying to make sure that you surround
yourself with people who are kind of on
that same path or have the same goals as
you uh whether that be like in a work
setting or like in like even like slack
communities and discords that you might
find um where people are learning cloud
so yeah on to the next question around
advice for people who are just starting
off in the cloud Journey because I think
that's going to be a lot of people who
are watching this live stream um of how
you know how to get into cloud in 2024
pretty much so maybe let's start back
from yourish and uh what would you say
is the top advice you would give to
people who are new to the cloud and want
to upskill in the hopes of learning a
job within this year or next
year good so uh I would I would give a
simple advice that start with the plan
if you just start randomly learning
something or randomly watching a video
without knowing where you are probably
it will take too much time for you to
reach where you want to so work backward
like we call in Amazon world so just try
to start working backward see that okay
I want to become a solution architect I
want want to become a software developer
I want to become XYZ let's see what are
the positions available for that profile
and what skills they are looking for and
then I chalk out what my skills are and
then I can start looking into okay they
require me to have knowledge of XYZ
language they want me to understand this
technology do I know that if not let me
start to fill that Gap so start backward
see where you want to be in maybe next
two years and what skills may be
required for it and afterwards start
looking into that what gaps you have and
what resources are available for you to
fill up those gaps so that would be
first advice to start backward second
would be to reach out to people who are
in the same role which you want to be I
would say because of this social media
thing it is so easy to reach out to
anyone and I feel that sometime you get
more help from a stranger than the
person you know very much so don't feel
shy don't hold your a backward let not
your ego come in front that why I should
reach out just reach out maybe you will
not get response from everyone maybe you
try 10 times two people would be willing
to help you and what advice they give
you what resources they share that would
be so much easier for you to follow
along so where you want to be check that
chalk out that plan and reach out to
people who are in similar role and ask
for their advice that is what I would
say to anyone who want to start their
journey and I want to add one more thing
here like all these people who are on
the channel except me and Prasad anyone
who is watching it if you want to see
see how these people progress to where
they are please check into the book and
in book we have because of Lucy talked
about advice even Lucy's journey is
there and it's very inspiring so you
would find in that book there is a
advice section where everyone has given
advice alert and action so something
which can be tangible which I can start
with maybe it could be achieving a
certification maybe it would be
achieving a particular course or
something so in the book you would find
everyone's journey and advices alert and
action from everyone so that could be a
good motivation to get started if you
are just dragging your feet and you're
feeling loss probably you would start
there thank
you thanks aish uh we have a few people
in the comments thank you for your
advice as well so I think that res
really resonated with a lot of people uh
Julie so what about you what would you
say uh does it have to be your like top
advice or biggest advice it could be
like a few parts to it as well um
because I know sometimes it's hard to
just give give one piece of advice uh
but what would you say is your uh kind
of tips and maybe yeah just in general
of how people can learn a job this year
and upskill in the cloud I think one of
the most important things is the
training course that you choose so
especially for newbies you're going to
want a course that covers fundamentals
or leads you to where you can learn
fundamentals but then also you know like
my style of teaching is different than
Nails it's different than other people
at AWS so my style doesn't work for
everyone but there are so many people
out there that are creating training
courses you know you can find one that
that style works for you and helps
because everyone learns differently you
know training and learning is personal
um and then I would also check that
course not only for fundamentals but to
make sure that it's updated um it's not
dated and that the content is
accurate because when we're new you know
we don't know what we don't know so if
you take a course and it's dated or it
has inaccurate content we don't know
that so it's just some tips that really
helped me that I kind of struggled with
when I started
out yeah and there's so many different
ways to learn right there's uh I know
now there's like even like Cloud Quest
where you can embark on like a game
Adventure um or you can do those
traditional video courses or sometimes
there's like classroom Based training I
know that in certain locations now
there's even um in person like training
classes so a lot of different options
and um I agree with you know like
everyone learns differently so just
because one of your friends brought this
course or like they they learn Cloud a
certain way doesn't mean that um it will
be like the ideal path for you so it's
just kind of spending a bit more time
trying to figure out what's the best way
and what works for
you so Neil um what would you say is
your top advice um based off of you know
all the um people that you've seen gone
through your different programs what
would you say um what what tips would
you have for them yeah so I I would Echo
um what's previously previously being
said which is that you got to start with
the fundamentals um and I would add on
to that to say try not to be too
distracted so there's so much
distraction today um so think about what
are the fundamentals as Ashish mentioned
work out what job role you're going for
if you're more software development than
Solutions architecture then it makes a
bit of a difference but it's not a mass
mve difference so there's a lot of
commonality across different job roles
so what you want to do is try and work
out exactly what are the skills I need
for example it might be AWS it might be
a bit of python it might be a bit of
Linux it might be a bit of terraform
those are the sorts of skills you'll
find across so many different job roles
so work out what are the fundamentals
you need to learn and then try and focus
on those and as Julie mentioned just
find the the training provider the
training courses that you know you like
the best that that work and resonate
with you um and work out a plan so just
have a good plan and stick to the plan
and then it's just a matter of time then
it's just putting in the effort
consistently and
learning yeah I think uh what you said
at the end was pretty comforting for
cloud beginners just kind of like having
a plan and trusting that process that
it's going to work out you know put in
the time to study and you'll get the
results at the end of the day so Sammy
uh what was what would be your top
advice uh I always see the 3 l which is
learn Le and lead and it's not just by
by the time you hit the lead you're done
you go back to learn Le and Le so what I
mean is that learning is basically find
a way to get you up skill very fast
certification is wonderful to find the
gaps you don't have the Gap you get it
also but after you read the book don't
try to copy hours a journey be your own
find out your how you work the best and
also when you learn think business value
technical people solve business problem
if you don't solve business problem you
don't have a job trust me the second
part is what how you going to believe it
is basically you can do the project and
apply what you learn to your job but
that means action I can read all the
books how to run marathon I don't go out
and run you I'm never able to go to mile
number one or first kilometer and
another thing is sharing when you are
enjoy what you are doing you have to
share with other which make you become a
better uh Mentor learner because you
have to tell how the people do then you
find now you don't know something then
you go back to learn which repeat the
journey and the more you learn you have
one more thing you get better you become
a better faster learner and that skills
is most valuable than your technical
skills because that you can learn
anything and good for your career
too yeah that's a good point um that you
mentioned with teaching I think uh
that's one of the best ways to learn
like learning something and then
teaching uh kind of someone who has been
in a situation like maybe six months ago
and then just kind of sharing that
knowledge to them uh because it really
challenges you on like whether you know
everything and what gaps you have in
your knowledge like sometimes they might
ask questions on uh so how does this
service really work and then you have to
go back and check on the documentation
to be able to answer that question for
them so prad um what would be your top
advice for cloud
Learners sure so my top advice is learn
in
public and this advice I'll explain what
learn in public means but this advice
comes from uh the distilling the entire
book so book has 16 stories and as I
mentioned each stories we have a
included a section called AA a AAA is
action advice alert so there are top
nine tips top three actions that you can
take top three advice that you will get
and top three alerts or mistakes that
you should be avoiding every story has
these nine tips uh in it from the
person's individual journey and we have
16 stories so that makes up 16 into 9
144 tips for you in the book now
obviously there are tips that are
overlapping like and more a tip is
overlapped across multiple stories means
more important a tip is now the tip that
I'm sharing leared in public has stuck
with me because I'll share example of
whether it is Daniel who has
transitioned his career from a taxi
driver to a cloud engineer or ifani who
has transitioned his career from a
athlete a track athlete to a cloud
engineer they have been learning in
public whatever they have learned the
basic thing even if they written a hello
world program in pyth
they have posted it on LinkedIn or
social other social media channels and
they have learned in public that has
helped them with two things first of all
they become more
confident if they are doing anything
wrong Community is so helpful that
they're going to tell you in private
this is how you can do it better no is
going you know don't be shy in you know
if what I'm posting if it's technically
wrong Community will be helpful in
making you better and
thirdly your potential employers are
noticing you both Daniel and ifani had
employees reaching out to them because
of their social media post and offered
them jobs so that would be my number one
tip if you're starting out and you're
looking for you know getting a job learn
in public and don't shy away from
sharing anything and it can be the
medium that you're comfortable with it
can be short form post on Linkin it can
be a long form post on medium it can be
a quick videos uh on YouTube shorts on
Tik Tok whatever you would like right it
doesn't matter but put yourself out
there while you are learning share with
everyone
awesome that's something I can attest to
as well I started off as an Amazon
intern back then and every part of the
journey whether that be passing
certifications or sharing my Reflections
I was posting that on LinkedIn and then
that kind of just progressed to YouTube
videos and then now I'm doing this
full-time so uh it definitely can bring
you a lot of different benefits even if
you don't want to in the end become like
a full-time Creator I think uh just
these days having a personal brand is
just so important and uh it brings about
so many benefits as You'
mentioned so yeah I think that's about
all the questions that we have prepared
uh I've been monitoring the comments as
well people have been um thanking all of
you for your responses and also just
saying a the content stop you for a
minute we want to learn your advice also
so yeah we shared Our advice we want to
hear your advice also so what you would
advise to someone who is starting the
cloud Journey you've been in an intern
in AWS you've been a solution now you're
running a successful YouTube channel
full-time content what would be your
advice I think all of my advice has been
covered uh throughout this live stream
which is good but I would say uh just a
bit of what everyone has already covered
um with the emphasis of building in
public uh just starting out like instead
of just thinking what should I learn
just like start somewhere um go Broad
and then go deep after uh I think seek
mentorship whether that be uh paid
consultations or throughout the
community uh by reaching out to people
and also just getting your fundamentals
sorted uh learn what the cloud is why
people should be learn learning cloud or
moving on to the cloud and then when you
have that knowledge teaching that to
others and then uh you know because the
best way to teach um to learn is to then
teach it and hopefully in the future uh
for people who are watching all of you
who end up learning jobs in the Cloud uh
would then go back into the community
and contribute in your own way whether
that be you know yeah as prad is showing
you know that cycle yeah uh would that
be making a YouTube channel yourself or
uh providing mentorship to others or
maybe even building a course to share
what you've learned uh that yeah that's
pretty much my advice as well uh just a
recap of everyone else's uh kind of set
in my own words uh yeah that that's a
good time I think to wrap things up now
now uh we're about 45 minutes into the
live stream and as I was mentioning
earlier thank you all so much for
actively engaging in the comments um a
lot of thank yous uh a few questions
that um I'm seeing but overall I'm glad
that everyone has enjoyed the session
and thank you all so much to all the
panelists for your time today I know
we're all across different time zones so
thank you all so much for accommodating
and yeah um I'll leave in the comments
as well later on just the contact
details to each of the panelists if
you'd like to give them a follow on
LinkedIn or their other socials but yeah
that pretty much wraps things up thank
you so much everyone again for joining
and yeah until next time bye for
now thank you everyone thanks for having
us Lucy all right thank you you bye
bye